sage Steele is here ESPN morning
SportsCenter Haute let me get the
official introduction she's returned to
Bristol after being away for four years
debut is Monday August 28th that would
be SportsCenter am from 7:00 until 10:00
Eastern you can watch from 7:00 until
9:00 sage says and then turn over to
this show that's nice of you saying that
with J Harris and Randy Scott Randall
Scott there which a Harris how are you
I'm great and thank you for inviting me
here Milford Connecticut yeah I can
check it off the Buffett bucket list now
yeah this was on your bucket sir really
top three top three okay
is is this show on in the newsroom Dan
what really wait no
however ask me about homes oh no I want
to know about at work so you haven't
been there in four years so I'll let you
know
but I'm guessing no not that we don't
love you but right well I do I just I
want to be on the radar of the
mothership
that's all I just and do you remember
your first SportsCenter Oh unfortunately
yes
cuz rece davis talked about his first
SportsCenter and he thought his job was
hanging in the balance he said he could
forehand or after before and after yeah
and and he said he got a call from Keith
Oberman and said you deserve to be in
the rotation you deserve to be there he
said he thought that his career was
really at a crossroads if he was gonna
get kept he said that yesterday
did you feel vulnerable after your first
SportsCenter
what's a stronger word I pretty sure
that I wouldn't be asked back ever again
and I would have understood it frankly
because it was that bad why because I
was horrid I mean I was number one I was
scared to death I had just seen Dan
Patrick in the hallways the week before
and I no no no it is and you're like
yeah who's the intern and kept walking
that is not a - I did not say you're
you're nice you were you are nice you
were nice
no but seriously you Stuart Scott I mean
you guys are the reason why
I wanted to work at ESPN seriously so so
it was a big deal and you were still
there I was a big deal to be there and
at what my first show wasn't planned
what time what did you do your show my
debut 6 p.m. SportsCenter oh well see
first of all I would never have had you
do a 6 p.m.
bingo right number one number two it was
the first day of the NCAA tournament
in March of 2007 so there's 956 scores
coming in at once no a one-hour show
went to two hours and 45 minutes cuz the
rundown was thrown out immediately
I was with Jay Harris actually so talk
about full circle ten years later coming
back to launch this show um I'd never
met dick by Tyler Digger Phelps ever
until I was walking over to do the
segment and I'll just leave it there
because the rest of it so needless to
say when I got done throughout two hours
three hours later I cried and I called
my husband almost like so um this this
place called Connecticut we won't be
living here long there's no way they're
gonna let me come back it was just too
much it was I was completely overwhelmed
and I fell in my face Paulie we have the
entire that entire Sports Center was
here today yeah here we go here's all
two hours and 45 minutes of that sports
I would vomit if I ever saw a clip of it
I mean was that bad was it the right
decision now and they told me later
we're sorry like basically no shot at
succeeding there however like I I
learned from it right you can't can't go
down from there I had to go up only one
way when did you feel like okay I can do
this for a living well before I got the
ESPN I thought I could and then that
happened and literally it took me at at
least two years to get my confidence
back up and here's the funny thing I was
convinced that I would not get renewed
to get another contract was a three-year
deal and I was pretty sure I actually
started selling skin care on the side so
I was working like 5:00 a.m. to 1:00
p.m. Mike and Mike updates first take
because I was out of the sports and a
rotation immediately and so I went from
assuming I'd be on nights and I was
coming in with three babies and you know
two early mornings so whatever did that
so 1:00 p.m. get off and then I'd go
home say hi to the kids and I would go
to women's houses and set up my little
skincare line and wine and cheese and
beg them to buy these
because I'm the breadwinner I was like I
have to support my family and there's no
way they're renewing me I was scared to
death and then I got mad and I got
really ticked off that I would allow you
know a couple of bad decisions and a bad
performance to get in my head and affect
my whole career and something clicked
and it changed in time to get another
deal because if you look at this
situation sometimes people get put into
these situations at a young age I
thought Jason Jackson who I loved dearly
was put into an early Sports Center and
he wasn't ready for it and then people
have their impression of you management
looks at you differently then all of a
sudden they demote you or you get the
feeling you're demoted now I'm just an
update person here I'll never get a
chance to do sports center again and
then you start to go is this what I want
to do with my life which is why I
started selling skincare $80 face
moisturizer but but you don't need that
when it's too expensive just buy the one
for 45 like horrid why don't you do it
now I would do it in addition to you
could really do it I mean you could do
it now look at you who would know that
you're 55 and I'm only half so thank you
Dad all right well it's age I'm gonna
make him feel awkward now it's age due
by the way McLovin has this story
can we tell the story to Saint that
story where you say it's not even much
of a story okay your brother works for
the Ravens yeah yeah so Real Talk what
is he six five six eight he's like six
eight almost like 240 big guy so you
can't you can't miss him he's always
there McLovin goes up to him and oh it's
so nice to meet you a Hall of Famer
tight end we're the greatest ever
basketball player
nice to meet you Tony Gonzalez oh yeah
do you know how often he gets that for
Tony Gonzalez literally once a week all
within there do you feel better now
because he was beating himself up no no
it happened all the time and actually
when Tony and chatter together they take
pictures the problem is you know I
covered the Ravens for four seasons
while he was the PR guy talk about
awkward when I'm like
hey I have to ask permission to
interview Ray Lewis he's like no
remember in third grade but he told Dad
that I would call my dad and is like
daddy and then anyway lungs hurt but
point is we would be literally on the
road in Cleveland and fans line up near
Lake don't Egon I'm like first of all
wrong teams with Chiefs at this point
secondly or maybe Atlanta anyway
secondly Chad's like do you want to see
my checkbook let me tell you I am NOT
Tony but they look they look alike yes
we Club even more embarrassing when I
went up we'll take a break here when we
come back I want to ask you about the
Ravens they reportedly brought in Colin
Kaepernick I want to ask you about the
Kaepernick rally a protest yesterday
your thoughts on that a few other things
will continue with sage Steele who the
job is now permanent you've made it I
just moved back here Dan I came from
Scottsdale Arizona back to Avon
Connecticut yeah it's you can't tell the
difference can you yep
we'll continue with Steve steel he's
returned to Bristol after being away for
four years and coming up Monday August
28th anchoring Sports Center a.m. from
7:00 till 10:00 until 9:00 and then
after that I like to watch myself Jay
Harris and Randy Scott and if you want
to give a shout out you can like if you
say you know this reminds me of when Dan
Patrick used to do Sports Center you
know the ground many moons ago were you
afraid to come up to say it was nervous
to say hi Danny because you're Dan you
you were Dan Pat I was didn't know it's
not a big deal
no honestly and and I think that like
you have to appreciate what you did what
you all accomplished you still walk
around these buildings and there's even
more buildings and your picture is all
over it still works picture of coal but
Stuart didn't do anything wrong he
didn't leave I left you but but it's not
even about sure certainly means picture
is these pictures there's people all
over because you built it you made it
that way don't you think they should
name buildings like Tommy should have a
building named
well that's different no I don't want a
building but I'm saying I think that
that would be great too to respond to
Bob Lee Chris Berman tommy's there is no
sports center and if they don't get
there and gut it out and honor them Nike
does this on their campus in with their
athletes but I think it'd be wonderful
if you you could have a ceremony
ESPN loves to have ceremonies you could
have Kris there Bob there Tom Mises wife
and you could have something really cool
I think I I don't think there'd be any
opposition to it
I just wonder I mean there's a lot of
names to choose from they know just
those three buildings just just those
three because the last thing I want to
do is go on campus for a ribbon-cutting
ceremony and my name on a building there
you would totally no I would not
yes you it's your idea you would have to
go and it's an I take away the idea it
means I have to go there then I don't
want to go but those three should be
honored Mount Rushmore only has three
names in my opinion in ESPN it's Chris
and Tom and Bob because what they did it
was before anybody wanted to do it
you're right before anybody watched
before any of it but maybe the fourth
head it would be Keith and I with two
heads coming out of one body I think
that's the expressions on your faces
what would Keith's expression be angry
passionate passionate all right let me
ask you about this with Colin Kaepernick
because your your brother works for the
Ravens I don't know if you talked to him
privately about this did Kaepernick come
in did the owner not want him did
management want him why didn't it work
out in Baltimore considering Ray Lewis
and Ray Rice were accepted welcome back
why not Seattle where everybody is a
free speaker free thinker first of all I
don't we don't talk about things because
it's it's best not to we have very
different opinions on most things I mean
I'm the enemy right he is the enemy in
the eyes of many PR but would he be on
would your brother you probably wouldn't
I should ask him but at the end of the
day um can I ask him go for it yeah let
me ask ad
but I feel like the the owner kind of
put this out there for public
consumption I just I just disagree with
the whole premise of the issue that
people have Steve bisciotti along with
the other 31 owners in this league they
run a business yes and they have a right
to make the decision that they believe
is best for their business just like
Colin Kaepernick has the right to
express his opinion and do its best for
him for his brand for his career there's
repercussions to both I have no problem
with what Steve bisciotti did and I
would have no problem if Steve bisciotti
had brought him in how much of a problem
did we have with Jerry Jones with Greg
Hardy over the last couple of years you
know people pick and choose what they
want to freak out about New York City
yesterday I mean go for it that is your
right I think it's comical I think that
if he of Colin Kaepernick I just think
he would still be on the niners if he
were that good other teams would have
picked him up people need talent there's
no question about that right if he were
that good
someone would have picked him up or
maybe he is and these team owners the PR
staffs say is it worth it because the
fallout that comes with it fans sweet
luxury box holders right there was a lot
of money involved in that and and you
have to consider all those things as a
business owner that is his right to say
we don't want to really go there and by
the way Ray Lewis back in 201 2000
completely different time more serious
of course he was never convicted of that
and people forget that Ray Rice
obviously things work themselves out as
they should have in my opinion but we
pick and choose and I think it's
fascinating that that oh this is a big
deal and this is not they are business
owners they have a right but I also look
at it is if you disagree with Colin
Kaepernick you're somehow racist and if
you stand in his corner then you're
unpatriotic there there's there's people
wanted simplified like that's the
problem that this isn't simple you're
not a racist if you disagree with what
he's standing or kneeling about and
you're not unpatriotic if you choose to
do it in the way that he did it
I don't like that he did it
way I understand why he did it that way
same page that's wrong I agree but but
it feels like we wanted compartmentalize
I know and that's my problem with it I
don't I still think I don't know what
you think of this I think he likes being
a martyr I think it helps his cause more
that he's not playing football I think
the longer that he plays or you know the
plays this out doesn't play football the
more this grows you see the protest now
it's growing I don't know where it's
going but it's growing if he plays and
he's a backup quarterback I think it
goes away I do too or it will it will be
you know every single snap he takes will
be completely over scrutinized but then
it does go away especially if he's not
starting I mean it looked back at the
Michael Vick situation right and and
there was one team as far as I know that
was willing to take him on and and that
was that was costly that that was a big
deal but but Michael Vick was still a
talent at that point and the other 31
teams said no were good so and but isn't
it the over coverage of this that Colin
Kaepernick probably and by the way what
has he said has he done anything exactly
so that's on the media and trust me I
have a problem with it I I do not look
forward to discussing this on
SportsCenter
I really don't get ready well but but
and we are gonna be doing things a
little bit differently I mean we are
gonna be doing on an NFL Mondays that
you will see every highlight from every
game played on Sunday everyone doesn't
mean they're all gonna be two minutes
but we're we're getting back to that to
more sports
I know god forbid and and not that we
haven't done it on other shows but that
was a key for me so these discussions
need to be had and there are there
crossover topics like this that will be
discussed but you know I'm talking to
her metrics and they don't want to talk
about it all the time either because it
is what it is there's news on it
know so move on would you have talked
about Robert Lee the football
broadcaster being taken off the virginia
game on your SportsCenter of course not
why i know i don't believe that we would
have done that because it's Colin
Kaepernick is an NF is an athlete but
this got big that I know it's in-house
I'm surprised ESPN reacted the way they
did with you know taking him off the
game
and somebody leaked it and that's where
it looks like from what I know and I
really shouldn't even go to folks I
don't know all the facts but this was
more about Robert Lee being
uncomfortable he's going on not ESPN yes
this is more about Robert Lee okay
yeah truly now after that the reactions
from there I don't know and we reached
out to talk to him because we haven't
heard you know if he was uncomfortable
in Charlotte yes with with those people
saying I wonder and and Robert Lee not I
think we're trying to protect him but
but but not at all Bristol's saying oh
my goodness yeah look at the name we
better take it no no it's not true
yeah and I I don't mean to put you in a
delicate position but you're talking
about what Sports Center is and what you
can and cannot talk about and what we
would have been given the format what
you do it today if you're hosting yes on
ESPN yes and what would how would you
cover it like well I would I would I
would want to have him on
I would ask John skipper for comment on
this what she's given yeah so I I
wouldn't want him to come on man
remember the show playmakers yeah I I
was told I was not allowed to talk about
playmakers and and I brought in mark
Shapiro like I he said you can't you
know you can't he called down to when we
were on radio and he was on the show
from his office at ESPN about playmakers
because the NFL NFL did not like
playmakers at all and I went this is you
know this is loosely based on all of
this why can't we talk about this why
can't you talk about your I mean maybe
we could I it's not something that I
would bring up in a meeting and say we
should really talk about this because
then it's like oh we're sitting there
defending ourselves or something the
Colin Kaepernick is is is a completely
different situation that I do believe
deserves to be talked about not
incessantly but is defending itself over
Robert Lee so you're doing it whether
that yeah at some point you have to and
again I'm not a PR person I don't want
that job anytime soon anywhere much less
ESPN I don't know I did I just don't
here's the thing when I turn on
SportsCenter that's not what I wanted
here as a vehicle what I want I want to
talk about I want to see the highlights
I want to talk about I want to hear from
rich Hill that's what I want as a viewer
and that's what I believe most viewers
want when they turned to ESPN dude it's
less did we get away when did we get
away from that ten years ago yeah but we
allowed first take to happen is that is
that's where you can talk about these
things that you can't talk about on
SportsCenter is that fair
it's a completely different show it's a
talk show where you talk about those
things and then you debate about those
things yeah SportsCenter that's not what
it has ever been
we've brought more conversation into it
and many times important conversation
many times not a lot of things I don't
like you know I mean back in the day
however many years ago with Tebow I
don't want to talk about Tebow okay
and he's a friend of mine people just
wants to talk about Tebow every day now
he works for her so it's all good
but there's a lot of these are the kind
of discussions though that we'll have in
meetings and need to be talked about and
what's what's the best way to cover it
but I will always go back to why did
people turn us on when Dan Patrick and
Keith Olbermann were hosting and why are
they turning us net us on now and in my
opinion it is not here about
Charlottesville it's not yeah I mean
it's fair but I'm wondering though
everything it feels like has to be a hot
take you have to have an opinion on
everything there I understand or take
that's not what we're gonna be doing we
will have some opinions the three of us
but I don't believe it's about us oh
good it's about the games it's about the
highlights it's about [ __ ] let's show
some standings let's talk about what's
coming up tonight I mean I'm just old I
guess no but that's cool I but I I like
that it was that Keith and I had a
built-in audience because you couldn't
see these highlights it's what you do
with the highlights how you make it
different for the consumer to tune in
and go I've already seen it now what do
you do that's the challenge and what
they've seen on their phones and their
devices is a 25 second clip of something
you're usually not that I sit there on
your phone and watch a two-minute
highlight and then what does it mean
afterwards and have her med where's our
Hasselbeck right there as well so you'll
get a clip but there's a lot more to
every highlights a story you know it's
not just the home run what happened
before the home run and that's what I
still think we can bring that's
different
I'm glad you're back I'm thrilled to be
I'm a wimp I'm gonna be freezing cold
I'm gonna need antidepressant medication
no I'm a loser when it comes to weather
and I admit it and I'm scared for
January but I'm really excited to be
back I've actually missed that the
campus you know I'd like to fill in when
Randy Scott goes on vacation I'd like to
fill in maybe one day you just said you
don't want to come on camp even a
building I don't want to build it if you
don't get me a building and I'd like to
come on I would love it would you
actually follow through with it they
allow me to walk on from like the 7:30
till like 8:15 have a helicopter bring
you quickly like that I like 7:30 to
8:00 o'clock and then I could get down
here in time to do they totally think
that you think they would absolutely
don't even run it by them well I signed
my contract secure there JJ's been there
for 14 years
absolutely that would be great would you
do it are you just talking I would
consider it because yes I owe it to you
that's the least you could do that's the
least I could do for putting those hot
women in bikinis up make me
self-conscious oh those are swimsuits
Alice yeah they're airbrushed you're not
airbrushed look at that beauty Pauly
am i serious that I would walk on with
this age and Jay Harris 45% series 45
anybody have a higher percent Fritzi I'm
gonna say 76% okay right yeah I see I
just I trust you Dan yes you should
trust you that you would follow through
that you're being serious now do they
still have the guard with the gun as you
come in the gate they don't have that
anymore right they do not have that sage
Steele is back on SportsCenter and who
knows I might stop in and say hello 7:00
until 10:00 Eastern with Jay Harris we
love Randall Scott is there as well at
debuts Monday he used to be a stand-up
comedian that guy you need to come on
with Randall I love his socks August
28th Monday
same steals back in the building at the
mothership
we're back after this on the Dan Patrick
show
it's sage and Dan in the morning the new
radio show here yeah oh my god you don't
have to go back to SportsCenter what if
I said you could have this job or go
back to school this is really for me I
don't know if you could handle like a
day every day with me that this is this
is my morning version it gets it gets
crazy you get crazy you do what I have
to tidy this place up because I don't
I'm a slob oh then you're okay with it
but I get louder and my hair gets bigger
and I mean you never know doodoo beer
and wings
I do do beer okay that's good sage and
Dan in the morning we need some good
music yeah yeah all right fritzy could
you sing a theme song for its age and
[Music]
rank yeah it's on short notice all right
would you guys discuss like who's more
handsome Brady or Garoppolo would that
be something brought up on SportsCenter
really do you want do you want my answer
yes looks alone yeah yeah Brady Brady
but I usually go darker hair a Gruffalo
I know if Garoppolo have you seen enough
of it's a win-win situation
these are the kind of things we discuss
the important a few yeah you would have
to discuss these things
oh absolutely we had a hot guy draft
last year you did yes yeah I think
Herbstreit might have been in it I think
Jesse Palmer - I mean naturally The
Bachelor of course of course yes boy
David Carr for NFL Network with the
Hydra I mean no give me one that you
might Ryan Reynolds was a high draft
pick the actor he's had who else do we
josh duhamel undrafted then called and I
find out about it yeah absolutely Josh
Josh that's right yeah yeah my wife is
like when you haven't Josh Duhamel on
again I go what are you talking about
yeah so bring your breakfast yeah hey
yep Josh Duhamel in the studio
sage and Dan and
morning I'm not gonna I'm gonna stop by
and say hello to you and Jay Harris and
maybe Randall case Scott will be there
as well we'll make some TV magic on the
mothership all right you got to go now
okay you're kicking me out
gotta go I made him nervous if only his
pants I gotta go I think I made you
nervous with all this okay bring it the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience